you're standing in a street in a british
town in the late victorian era
the old queens still on the throne it's
a time between the old world and the new
it's a winter's night cold and moonless
you should also imagine one more thing
there's electric street light
high off the ground the lamp is
flickering and hissing
underneath the street light stands a
woman
she has an intelligent determined face
and curly hair pinned in a mound on top
of her head
she's staring up at the electric light
it's an arc lamp a wisp of lightning
crackling between two electrodes
she's listening to the hiss
noticing that when the ark buzzes
the light dims
she knows those lights throw off sparks
they can start fires
she's imagining a future where electric
light could be bright
even and safe
she's thinking
how can i make that happen
her to marx etten had always had to be
ingenious
born into a jewish family in portsmouth
in 1854 her father was dead by the time
she was seven
leaving the family with little more than
a pile of debt
but her to marx etten was what you might
call a bright spark and always inventive
she was stubborn tomboyish and outspoken
every evening for a year after a full
day of work mark said studied for the
cambridge university entrance exam
she passed in 1874 with honours in
mathematics and english
she was an astonishingly hard worker and
made her first recorded invention a
sphygmomanometer
that would draw a graph of a person's
pulse
after graduating she carried on teaching
and inventing
in 1888 she delivered a series of six
hugely popular public lectures on
electricity
in which she held out to her audience a
compelling vision of an electrified
future
electric arc lights were used in street
lamps
they provided incredibly bright
lightning in a bottle
but they were volatile and poorly
understood
to make them safe and reliable
someone needed to invent a way to
precisely control their dangerous
temperamental power
so her to mark that and asked herself
why did arc lights flicker
and how could she stop them doing it
she put together an intricate and
comprehensive set of experiments to test
out every possibility she often had to
hold the arc steady by hand for four or
five hours to get consistent results
and marxaton deduced the electric arc
hissed when oxygen was present in small
craters in the carbon surface
the hiss
was the sound of the carbon oxidizing
to stop this happening herta marxarton
invented and patented a new kind of
carbon rod
coated with a copper film
to stop oxygen reaching the sides of the
electrodes
as she predicted this gave a steadier
arc a more dependable light
to marx airton wanted to make street
lights safer and she did
the arc light helped create a new after
dark world of working playing shopping
and exploring
she ended up sparking life into
detonators 3d printing and maybe one day
rocket launchers for space travel
her to mark zerton tamed lightning
the ark that burned so brightly between
the electrodes of those early lights was
uncontrollable
a wisp of lightning if you like
mark zetten got that lightning under her
control and gave it to the world
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video